well nowadays spread fake news with
tadashi or the idea that the election
was stolen
did you just spread it okay through
destabilizing the the presidency and
track they won Pulitzers for it go back
grab the person by the hair who's
awarding the public service alright so
before we move on to advisors
question of the day now that Muller's
determined there has been no collusion
do you think that President Trump has a
much stronger chance of winning
reelection in 2020 what do you think
doughnuts have left a campaign on I
don't let me know below and what your
takeaways have been I'm critical here
are the top takeaways because it's been
tough it's tough to piecemeal the news
sometimes with takeaways from the report
let's give you some context the model
investigation finally concluded two
years twenty-five to fifty million
taxpayer down depending on who you ask
it's really just a rounding span of
numbers top takeaways from the report in
my opinion number one obviously there's
been no collusion even mainstream
leftist news outlets like MSNBC have
finally been forced and it hurts so you
can see this through their face they
have to admit the truth and Robert
Muller has waited and said that was not
tacit there was no coordination or
conspiracy
so this vindicates the President on
collusion it does so it would the
decayed amount collusion a gift she
looks like that one Muppet maybe when it
gets smashed by the other Muppet baby
with a frying pan
I have to be up here so not a single
charge related to the election Russia
collusion anyway form fossa okay it's
important to by the way something else
that people have forgotten this is the
same result as two other already
finished investigations the Senate the
house intelligence committees okay so
now three investigations twenty five to
fifteen million dollars depending when
you ask later nothing nothing and
another left is going to this what you
see on media they're going what about
man afford okay
sure metaphor it's an ass yeah Trump to
colluding with Russia the investigation
this is what's important the
investigation was not to find out if
Trump was a bad guy potential wasn't it
find out as long as people worked in the
campaign they have to get some crappy
things okay
it wasn't even to find out if someone
somewhere in connection to president
Trump acted negligently the
investigation was predicated on with the
express purpose of finding direct
evidence of Trump colluding with the
Russians to win the election he is
squeaky clean which amazes me well in
look they didn't say that Trump had some
bad contact it he didn't had some
influence that was outside that he said
he colluded with the Russians to steal
this election from Hillary Clinton that
was the claim the entire time and
Democrats came forward one after the
other
well I've seen reports in Trump
absolutely did there's no way he's
getting out of this one my girlfriend's
cousins boyfriend knows this guy yeah
Donald Trump hang out with Putin at 31
flavors last and yes by the way they
also complained about Comey
pretty sound Trump obstructed the
investigation first off the president
has the right to fire come--it will and
he did and we already know that Comey
was doing huge favors for Hillary
bringing no charges even though he found
her guilty of pretty much everything
she'd been accused of doing by the way
so the reason the president Trump likely
fired coming was because yes he thought
it was a politically motivated
witch-hunt yeah because it was a
politically motivated which one how can
you justify charging obstruction of
justice now is what they're talking
about if how can you say obstruction of
justice if there's no evidence of a
crime committed at all what justice was
he obstructing none I'd be like uh can I
see your driver's license registration
yes officer I think you know drugs in
your car no officer I do not well I want
to search your vehicle I'm sorry I don't
believe that you have just cause I'm
charging you with resisting arrest
arrested for
and then you find out there's nothing
but a baby seat back there and now they
pick me up really so easy now release
the folder for report there's gotta be
something in there dear god I hope well
you're not gonna hear an argument from
me okay do it release the report I don't
care
you know you know who else doesn't care
you know who else doesn't care president
Trump yeah
now take five ten guys be done by a beta
you oughta release it the here's the
fight over releasing the report it's not
with President Trump he's fine within
it's irrelevant just like when Democrats
demanded at the Kavanagh hearings that
they include testimony from dr. Christie
Ford we okayed that they went through
all of it then it was clear that
Cavanaugh was innocent they demanded a
full FBI investigation which he never
opposed and he had already been vetted
by the FBI if you were to release the
full report right now what you're not
opposed to there is always going to be
something else and then something beyond
they're gonna continue to push the
Russia collusion conspiracy theory for
all time yeah but the prep the president
has work to do work can't stop because
people want to throw an [ __ ] tantrum
so here's my next segue introduce your
thoughts on this one things too entire
Russia investigates revealed to me its
lend a lot more credence to the what was
considered a conspirator the deep state
yeah something that the left is
routinely mocked as nothing more than
craziness comes the deep state is so
deeply buried in its DP deepness Sean
Hannity had to pull it from the depths
of his ass just to be clear that was the
nation's number-one cable news station
mainstreaming one of the far right and
far left's favorite conspiracy fever
dreams straight into our president's
gullible eye holes okay a few problems
here beyond it being less funny than the
image you were drawing special if you
can believe it you don't have to but you
don't have to take my word for it here
are some six-year-olds who are dead
LeVar Burton you made them watch Amy
Schumer and now so first the steel dasu
people forget about the russia--the it
was the senior dossier okay
this is the one that included all of the
charges Russia and collusion it was
created by a Democrat PR from fusion GPS
remember that it was fake and by the way
when people were talking about Trump jr.
meeting with the Russians the Russians
he met with worked for fusion GPS okay
somehow this goes completely ignored by
the look on it's funny that Trump is
connected to
you notice I saw this on Twitter Trump
is connected to Putin because he went
golfing with Kid Rock who were fantastic
pants by the way who knows a Hannah
Anderson who hangs out with Julian
Assange who apparently is a Russian
asset the steel dossier was leaked far
and not just a journalist but lawmakers
top-level intelligence officials and
they use the dossier as part of the
basis for this entire investigation and
it wasn't even close to being true if
you in it pulls in that like the FISA
courts they were dealing with all of
this stuff like right none of this stuff
was credible not all way it was way more
credible that this was actually all fake
and it was set up by the Democrats to
hurt Donald Trump than it was that
Donald Trump was sleeping with the
Russians to try to get the election well
we do have concrete evidence that
actually top intelligence agencies they
spied on President Trump yeah yeah
actively worked to remove him from
office and by the way and doesn't that
people forget the steal dasya people
just think like oh it's one thing that
was disproven no that actually had a
trickle-down effect it was used to push
a tough this is why it's been wall to
wall Russia yeah all over the media it
started with the steel dossier certainly
that was a catalyst for pissing
prostitutes or the BuzzFeed debacle it's
been going on and so so the question
here is is there a deep state all right
let me near bipartisan coalition in top
levels of government that actively
conspired to destabilize legitimate
president and call the question free and
fair elections and the media was
complicit one could say yes president
from office through proactive deception
let that sink in and before it sinks in
then remember they also want to do away
with the electoral college but it was
her turn Steven oh it was her turn it
was justified the main takeaway three
and I know people think we've been
repeating this ad nauseam but this is
very important to talk about today the
media okay
it's broken it's it's almost hard to
even begin to express the truth the past
two years every Network take your pick
publications they push this idea that
Trump colluded with Russian nuts up and
by the way we all said hey listen we
hope that we get to the bottom of this
yeah there's one of you don't believe if
you don't believe us then you're clear
really part of the alt-right was lost I
concluded with Russia I want this guy to
go out but I also want the guy to be
able to do his job they want they
accused anyone who didn't follow with
them last step just like me accuse
anyone who live in the Great Lakes and
didn't believe that Blake's would be
gone by the year 2017 that we were
stupid yeah they weren't even trying to
have an investigation they weren't
saying it's possible they were saying
this is fact and you have to believe it
and so much so that everybody thought we
had an illegitimate President on the
left right they thought that there was
no way that this actually happened and
justice must be served
right and it mean it makes people go
crazy maybe like they have no recourse
because somebody stole an election how
do you figure that
well nowadays spread fake news with the
dossier or the idea that the election
was stolen
did you just spread it okay through t
stabilizing the the presidency and track
they won Pulitzers for it
so keep in mind we're DeLorean right now
if we have the report three okay no rush
of collision go back grab the person by
the hair who's awarding the public
service don't they at least have to
change the word to for fiction now like
thing they have to go back in advance
they just assumed that that's the the
mulatto guy who looks like the photo
negative of Alfred Newman would bring
world peace never mind that he was the
first president to be it war for eight
years
ever throughout history thing his entire
like yours was constantly at war tough
one it's the same with Trump's they just
they knew the Russia collusion was real
so they began handing out awards for the
coverage didn't matter if were true or
false and what's the worst part all this
the media is entirely unapologetic now
that we know the entire narrative was
faked our anchors let's see are they
offering apologies at CNN no dead Johnny
Mathis is too busy hosting lemon parties
and his Upper West Side high-rise take
away number four
even after Muller found zero evidence of
collusion I guess I should label this so
we have four left this conspiracy
theorist I think they think that this
exists solely on the right yeah the
conspiracy here can we this one count
of odd this has to count oh it doesn't
complicate the New York Times wrote
about it understand okay so Democrats
and politics in the media they're still
pushing the conspiracy theory they're
even inventing more conspiracies
like completely unproven cover-ups did
the Democrats put too much trust in the
Muller report because I don't need the
Muller report to know he's a traitor I
have a TV I'll tell you what I see from
my perspective you have a present when
my opinion beyond the shadow of a doubt
sought to however ham had colluded with
the Russian government a foreign power
to undermine influence it feels like the
seeds of a cover-up are here well I mean
theoretically it could happen right it
feels like it and Bill Maher says I know
because I watch a TV namely when I'm on
do you say I know because I watch a TV
what's fake news anything that's not on
TV what about you I'm a comedian where
do you get your news on TV who's on TV
comedians remember how Democrats they
warned that conservatives had respect
the results of the Moller yeah change it
by the way they're saying is it I just
heard on CNN yesterday when I was
watching this Sunday morning I can't I
mean they're all so inconsequential but
she does listen isn't it inconsistent
for conservatives to now praise much to
now say that the mullah report indicates
that one they didn't want to happen it's
not inconsistent because they believe it
was a politically motivated witch-hunt
and even with that motive they still
could find nothing yeah it doesn't mean
that we like Muller it just means that
even with ever and he really wanted a
reason to make it stick
we weren't praising Allah we were
praising the report the report and it
was true and by the way I'm sure the
report is probably worse than it even
needed to be he didn't use it he didn't
use the microfiber cloth on a laptop and
he scratched it yeah you know he's an
a-hole that's gonna cost 500 bucks to
pick what the election member they kept
lecturing Republicans that they had to
respect the results of the election do
anything else will destroy the country
would undermine the very tapestry of a
constitution if the Constitution were
knitted I think I don't understand that
analogy was a catalyst dream like it's a
paper this is when they thought that
Hillary Clinton was going to win right
wouldn't rip one little marquee on the
rulebook
they still believe Trump colluded with
Russia despite no evidence just like
they believed that Brett Kavanaugh ran
rape gangs in high school and was
lighting candles in effigy to a Rams
head while putting her teenage daughter
in a Devil's Triangle can you think of
any other story that has gotten
much coverage from media based on the
presumption of a factual base which
turned out to be completely false
I can Brett Kavanaugh oh yeah this has
been going on for years they've been
screaming collusion for years and people
have been getting Pulitzers for
screaming collusion we now know beyond
any shadow of a doubt that there was no
collusion so now they're trying to say
that Trump obstructed the investigation
of a crime that he never committed this
is never going to end this is what I
think the most important takeaway here
is if we're talking on the left when
people like Pelosi when people have to
say I'm a centrist man and we need to
come together and we need to find
solutions I guarantee you this is never
going to end as soon as a report hit
Pelosi desk she just said we're just
gonna bridge gonna find something else
to stand for guarantee you guess what's
gonna have no interest in finding common
ground these people have no interest in
the constitutional republic that his
name is safe they just want to make
something stick on this guy be it true
or false and give each other awards for
it and by the way anyone if you're
trying to do a job think of it this way
and investigators are constantly
breaking down your door seizing your
tools bringing your friends and
employees into depositions taking their
computers anyone anyone would be pissed
and call it a witch-hunt
if you knew that they were accusing you
of something you didn't do so if you go
back and your DeLorean look at president
Trump's behavior okay look at how people
are saying look how erratic he is well
what an [ __ ] but now I want you to
change put that in the context of the
undeniable fact that he didn't do
anything wrong just like Brett Kavanaugh
was pissed because he knew that he
didn't do anything wrong
we'll give them all that [ __ ] why are
you angry Brett because you called me a
gang rapists and this upsets you of the
judge not gang rapists that's reasonable
fake news why are you upset because I
didn't do anything with the Russians and
they're mad that we're saying you did
you need a thicker skin if you look at
it through that prism anybody would go
crazy genuinely think of how pissed you
would be if at your workplace you were
harassed but right investigated
hamstrung as to your ability to complete
your job and all these nasty rumors I
don't know let's picture they were being
posted on the office blog despite you
knowing beyond a shadow of a doubt that
it's not true that's what President
Trump has had to deal with only on a
global scale tell me you wouldn't be
pissed and tell me now that you know
think a pissed president Trump wins
re-election hey there if you like this
video subscribe or click one of these
videos playing in a box you know what
hit the notification bail because
subscriptions don't really mean anything
anymore especially if you're not 18 or
older at the very least logged in to
YouTube is 18 or older because sometimes
people are 25 but they don't know how to
use the YouTube system properly and then
you never just take the notification pal
or you hate yourself